hmm hello it's your boy Sebastian the
high/low here today and I am back at the
Magnus trainer app so today I wanted to
do some tactics so I wanted to jump
right into the Rogers riddle mates which
is a brilliant brilliant game and the
reason why is because in chess it's all
about motives all the tactics are both
are about the motives and in this game
you learn to recognize the motors
motives and you learn to choose the
different motives and that is the reason
why I like it so let's see if I know the
difference between the Bolton's mate and
eat prowl let's mate however you
pronounce that I think it's a pilot to
mate so let's go for is how let me see
that is indeed the correct one wonderful
and if you have forgotten which one it
is you can click on this icon here and
now it will show you which one it is
alright okay this one is the similar
similar as the other one once again
bloody hard word to say opponent okay I
believe that is a GPL estimate once more
what are we pellets in this room all
right that is definitely a bonus mate
because that is nothing as far as I can
tell and this is an epaulette knife once
again what it's nothing you powe let me
oh ok because if I play Queen d6 sales
57 I did not see that ok fair enough
of course we're gonna play Bishop h6
chip f6 actually in this case alright
that is the first lesson I bet level 4
that is quite nice isn't it
so we will continue and we will move on
to a more advanced level let's try to do
level number 29 29 is a nice number so
let's go for that okay I'm excited about
the next made in mating patterns we will
get so we have Arabian made smothered
mate and EP left mates
once again I believe we will go for the
smothered mate because its mate unless
that was not correct no oh okay
the smaller this mother made this as you
say in a region it's clearly Mountain
oops I should have known that I I
completely messed that up okay let's try
again we will go for the smothered mate
right now which is again not correct
okay fair enough
[Music]
let's try again and I think it's a
pallet mate right now isn't it okay I
completely messed those two that is ugly
okay black to move this is definitely
the smaller mates because we have a
knife that is a nice classic this is
that region mate we did it not very
impressive but at least we did we did
beat level 29 and let's move up further
let's go to level number 48 okay get
ready I am ready this is the challenge
of my life
smaller mates once again let's see I
believe it's Bishop e7 followed by
Knight d7 and a 96 spider isn't easy one
very nice smother mates once again
go in with the night then we will play
nice to me six and rook - to where
exactly oh I see it could be five and
nights and more brilliant really nice
smother mates once again I actually
found it harder when you had to choose
between the different the mates somehow
which is interesting
all right so now it is some takes F 1 1
out of 2 if it takes a fair Queen to one
of course we take H 3 Queen G 1 and
night F 2 once again we have the
smothered mate 26 97 96 queen bee date
and 97 and that is level not now okay
that is noobest score I'm real happy
about this I am really happy so we did
beat level 48 once again this is a nice
tactic puzzle because it helps you train
the different motives and it helps you
recognize them during the game so that
has been everything from me today as
always I'm your host sebastian my love
and i will see you in the next one
[Music]